hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast animal and Sela enabling
integration in the lab of the future
presented by Burkhardt Schaffer
president at the SSN software I'm Alexis
Carlos of lab birds and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab birds laberd's
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Burkhardt Shaffer I will now turn the
presentation over to him thanks Alexis
and thanks for the invitation to be with
you here today
animal and sea light enabling
integration in the lab of the future so
what are we going to talk about we see
all of those efforts for digitization
and lab 4.0 and all of those bits and
pieces where we where we are trying to
to modernize and digitize the way we are
doing things in the lab but there are a
lot of challenges the first one being
well we keep speaking about this lab of
the future thing but what is it actually
and what could it deliver for us that's
actually what I want to start with in
the presentation today and then look at
how can we get there and part of that
connectivity and interoperability so how
do I get all of the different pieces in
my lab connected and talking to each
other and we'll be exploring two
interesting efforts the animal project
and the silicon sodium that enable that
type of interoperability animals from
the data side being a data standard
that's given by ASTM and Sheila a set of
communication protocols and that comes
from the silicon sodium both are fully
open and royalty-free and they've been
gaining quite a bit of traction recently
so I want to help you put the different
puzzle pieces together and help you at
least get a bit closer to this vision of
lab of the future so having said that
let's dive right in and first thing what
is the lab of the future and why would I
want one so what do I expect and and
obviously there are different
definitions and I'll share my personal
one with you and yours may be different
and please feel free to comment in the
in the Q&A panel if you if you want to
join on the discussion so what can the
lab of the future deliver and I've
grouped these ideas around four core
points here the first one is easy
provisioning so that I can set things up
and move things around and get going so
the time before I can do my first
experiment is as small as possible
the second one is scientific focus means
people should be focusing on getting the
science done rather than moving data
around and and all of it and the lab
should help me do my thing so I need to
worry less around those routine tasks
the third one being connectivity so I
have the different bits and pieces in my
lab the different instruments my
different data systems maybe a limb and
an ELN they need to talk how do I do
that
and the fourth sustainability and so
that my investment that I make into
those components today is protected and
I have a way for growing so let's
explore each of the
for in more detail and see what's behind
it and again it's my personal definition
feel free to jump in and discuss so the
first point here is provisioning how do
I actually set up my lab and with the
lab of the future people often associate
the start of an agile and flexible
deployment approach so I can go and mix
and match equipment from different
vendors with different measurement
techniques and bring together them in a
Best of Breed approach so they I can get
my science done and not have to worry
too much about getting everything set up
and provisioned and connected to each
other and we hope the lab of the future
is going to make that job of getting set
up and integrated easier second one is
scientific focus so we want to make sure
that we let the user in the lab focus on
getting the science done because that's
really why we have the lab in the first
place all right we want to take
everything else out of the way and we
don't want any more clumsy tools now
with we all love Excel and cutting and
pasting but you know please not too much
of that so we can do much better we can
do things like automatically capturing
the data feed from the instrument or be
it from from devices that are around me
I want still despite that that support
that I get from my from a digital
environment
I still want freedom to innovate and on
the R&D side but if I'm on the QC side
I'm more into guidance so I want that
guidance to be there and present but
unobtrusive so that again it doesn't get
in the way but it helps me get stuff
done so I can focus and part of that
focus is also making sure that I have
everything that I need so that
replenishment of any supplies or
consumables that I have happens
automatically or I get reminded when I
run low on something that I need
so that's scientific focus
for me next one is connectivity and
connectivity is about sharing all the
data with all the stakeholders and those
stakeholders would be and users you know
they want the result and then data
systems like my limbs my Ln or my data
analytics and visualization Suites which
I use to analyze the work that I've done
and share it with other people and one
thing to remember is the data that we
are generating out of a lab experiment
typically is the most important asset
that we generate from that investment in
time and money and in all of it so
that's the reason why that experiment is
being done because I want the results so
we need to make that data accessible now
we need to share that data with everyone
who needs it and that means we need to
connect with people who want that data
we need to connect with organizations
because that data might actually be of
interest to a customer of mine or to a
collaborator either in my organization
or elsewhere well I may be living in a
contract lab and and providing service
for others and then also connecting
systems so that the data can flow
between those systems without too much
manual intervention because that means a
waste of time but also I want to make
sure if I have that system to system
connectivity it's easier to get a higher
level of data integrity and connectivity
is a nice buzzword but how do I get that
and we want to talk about that in
particular today and there to make the
interfacing and connectivity easier
standards can be a great tool so we're
thinking about using instrument to
control standards such as Scylla or data
standards such as animal and we'll be
talking about these a bit more so that's
the third one on the lab of the future
benefits like this connectivity side of
things number for sustainability and
sustainability means well on the one
hand when I do my experiment I'm doing
it to generate that immediate result
that I wanted that I wanted so this was
the reason why I went into the lab in
the first place but there may be other
of using that data and I want to be
ready for that as well I might want to
analyze the data later and being
sustainable means I get not only to
reuse my data but also to reuse my tools
and ideally I can do that across vendors
and measurement techniques and that
would then allow me to reuse and
repurpose my data more easily and if I
add context to my data and annotating it
I can enable smart queries so I can find
that information again and draw new
conclusions out of it or see trends and
sometimes the regulator's ask me to keep
my data around for the long term and our
friends in the pharmaceutical industry
know what that's like but others are
also regulated in some way shape or form
and long term retention of that data is
also a very important aspect and if we
set up our our lab of the future
properly we can kill quite a few birds
with one stone and we've talked about
the connectivity we've talked about the
sustainability we've talked about the
scientific focus and if we use standards
to connect the things then those things
become easier to achieve so so far about
this lack of the future ideas and the
goals behind this so how do we actually
get there how can we achieve this and in
order to understand that a bit more I
will tell you first how it's being done
today and you may recognize some of
those someone else a phenomenon here so
the traditional integration between
let's say a Lim's system I have a lab
information management system and an
instrument so in the links I have an
order and that order should be executed
so I want this sample analyzed and then
I have the instrument that has the
capability to do it so what typically
happens is I create my sample in the
lineage and so on and then the Lim's
creates a worklist file that worklist
file is specific to the instrument that
i want to talk to and it drops that
worklist file into a folder now the
instrument software keeps watching that
for watching and watching hoping for
while to come I'm hoping that in the
moment I read it it's actually already
written and not still in progress and
then at some point ah there's a fine
here I'm gonna go and grab it and I
perform the run so the instrument
software performs the run now and once
it's done well hopefully it gets done
because if there are any errors I have
no way of knowing once it's done it's
gonna drop a proprietary result data
file in some other directory so just by
watching that directory I get a clue
okay the sample is probably done and
then I go and pull that folder from the
inside so the Lim's polls the folder and
then hopefully once that file is
completed it picks up the result file
and it doesn't pick it up just before it
finished writing the last few kilobytes
and then I have a broken file okay so if
so this will work and then the list goes
picks up the result files this is going
to be a different result file for every
instrument so I will have to configure
my linh specifically to understand that
file type and all of that so so that's
one way of doing it another alternative
approach here is the instruments of
death generates a PDF record this PDF
report is stored in some repositories
such as the scientific data management
system or SEMS and then we have a tool
that parses that PDF yes they do optical
character recognition on the PDF to pull
out values and then populate the limbs
with that so not ideal but this is
pretty much how it's being done today on
to a fairly large degree and you know we
can do better so the first thing is you
know why these files we need to get rid
of these files we need to make sure that
we get a proper control flow and a
proper data flow going so that it's not
a fragile construct where I drop a file
I hope something will happen I have no
idea whether the other system is
actually running I just hope it it's
running and picks up the file does the
work and eventually comes back to me
there is no status information there are
no events I can't send a command to that
instrument and when I get the data back
that data is in all kinds
performance so it's really hard to use
that data down the stream so what's our
what our learning from this well if I
want to do true integration I need two
things on the one hand I need
communication and dropping files
somewhere is not communication so we
need a proper communication protocol in
place now we'll talk about how we do
that and the second one is data
representation so I need one common way
ideally for representing that data so
that I have an easier way of consuming
that data downstream and and I think
standards can help a lot with that and
we'll see how so here is an example of
another type of integration so in this
case we have a balance that we are
connecting to aliens
could be an iln it could be other
systems using the limbs as an example
here so in a proprietary world which is
the world of today the balance vendor
will publish hopefully a proprietary
protocol that then the Lim's vendor can
pick up and implement and write a driver
for it and then the driver will speak
that proprietary protocol that the
balance understands and they can go back
and forth and and then that works then
the Lim's is connected to the balance
but for the next device the names
company will have to write yet another
driver now if I want to reuse that same
device that I already have connected to
my limbs but use it from my ELN well the
ELN has a completely different driver
architecture so I can't reuse the driver
so it's really a one-to-one connection
that I build all the time and from a
total cost of ownership perspective
that's a nightmare and but still we do
it and we do it because that is the
status quo and that's what we are
working on changing on with zealand
animal so if we go along with this with
this true integration idea we realized
very quickly that communication and data
really need each other why is that well
let's say I had an open communication
protocol that I could use to speak to
any instrument out there
and I could connect to it let's say over
the network I can I can ask it what kind
of commands do you have yeah and I'm
then I sent the commands this is all
nice and good but once I get my results
back the data is going to end up in a
Seidel because I don't have a common
file format if I only use a
communication protocol my data ends up
in silos again which I don't want so if
I in turn look at a file format so let's
say I had a data standard that describes
a file format well a file format alone
is not suitable for components that need
to communicate and we've just seen that
you drop a file you wait for it to get
picked up eventually and worked on and
that's not that's not enough and copying
files around is not communication so we
really need both for proper end to end
integration so if I want true
integration I need two things which
establish that I need communication and
for communication I use communication
standards so that I don't have to write
a separate driver for each instrument
and for data exchange I use data
standards so that I don't have to pass a
different data format for every
instrument and I want to receive data
from or send data to me
so a good example of of two
standardization efforts that that work
together very closely by the way is the
Silla consortium which is creating
communication standards and the animal
effort at ASTM which is standardizing
data formats for scientific instruments
and I'll be talking about both of these
and then we look a bit at how these can
get used in order to build a system that
actually communicates so Silla many of
you will will have heard about it Silla
is an organization that that creates
standards in laboratory automation as
the acronym as ila suggests and what
Sheila does primarily is it standardized
community
protocol and that communication protocol
is network based it's it uses modern web
technologies such as HTTP 2 and a number
of other cutting-edge technologies and
what that allows me to do is to have
services in the lab and those services
are provided by that's an instrument or
by limb system or by something else that
can do something for me then I have a
way of of talking to those services over
the network and I can ask them well what
type of service do you offer what are
you and then there are some common
functionalities that that the typical
instrument would have so if we stick to
the balanced example well a balance
would probably be able to tell me the
weight or it would expose a tare
function or it would allow me to
calibrate and depending on the
instrument type those commands would be
different you know and Celia calls this
a feature and the feature is a set of
standard commands that a certain type of
instrument offers so a balance would
have a particular set of commands and
hplc would have a different one an enema
would would have a different one and and
the microplate reader would have a
different one
and so what Silla does is two things on
the one hand the communication protocol
but also those standardized commands for
some common capabilities but on top of
that vendors and users are able to also
use additional commands that are not
part of the standard and still used as a
communication infrastructure for that so
if a vendor has additional capabilities
in an instrument and wants to expose
those capabilities using custom insular
commands they can do that and this will
not break compatibility with other
applications which is quite interesting
and so these features they grow over
time and it's an open process anyone can
contribute to features like that if you
think there should be a communication
protocol for talking to instrument X you
can join the effort and actually help
build it and you see Celia is really
about communication but you need to
remember that this is also about data
the
it's also about producing data and
seeing that doesn't address that which
is why there is a partnership between
Cielo and animal effort at ASTM where
animal is looking after the data format
and see lab can then be used as an
envelope to communicate that data
between an instrument and a system so
you see loud to talk to the instrument
to get it to do the things you wanted to
do and then you get a data package back
in animal format which is XML based and
then you can then you can use that data
and the Silla has about 1700 individuals
as members and and number of corporate
members and its primary active in Europe
and North America and there's a website
if you want to learn more it's a very
active community and that's about xenon
so next up we'll talk about animal now
just like cielo animal is an acronym
anything decent is an acronym these days
so animal stands for analytical
information markup language and it comes
from ASTM and it's an XML format for
analytical data it's also being used in
the biologic space and was built by a
consortium of industry academia vendors
and government bodies and this means
very broad set of stakeholders and it
can be hard to reach consensus and so
that took quite a while to build in fact
it took them over ten years to do so but
now you have agreement on what such a
data structure needs to be to support
all of those different use cases that
these different stakeholder groups have
and each member has the same rights so
this this effort is not dominated by a
particular industry or by vendors or by
you know certain certain particular
groups of interest but there is an equal
and level playing field and ASTM is good
at managing that and what what animal
allows us is to allow is to capture data
from a number of different analytical
techniques so it's not a format that can
just deal with
type of instrument it allows me to put
the data of any type of instrument in
there and I can combine these different
analytical techniques in the same file
even so if I have a sample and I run
let's say mass spec on it and NMR and I
also take a picture with the microscope
all those three items can go into the
same animal document and can all be
viewed using the same piece of software
which is very powerful
it means that I get to reuse the tools
that I have for many more instruments
and today and today classically my
instrument software only works with that
instrument that it came with right
and having vendor-neutral software
packages is quite a challenge but with a
standard like this it suddenly becomes a
reality and we are seeing that being
picked up so animal not only supports
capturing results but also capturing of
sample and process data that's important
so you get reproducibility so not only
does it store your chromatograms and
your peak tables and your calibration
curves and all that but it also captures
information about the sample about how
you set up the process the method the
instrument configuration the instrument
serial number the operator the the
software you used and many things like
that so you have reproducibility and
also traceability and for the regulated
communities there are audit trails and
digital signatures and also validation
capabilities build him so that these
types of datasets can also be used in a
regulated environment what animal is
focusing on is accessibility and easy
adoption so we have stories where where
companies have been able to implement
animal within a day and particular limbs
vendors or instrument vendors they they
just looked at it and they looked at a
couple of examples and then it was
really easy to pick up and to get going
and if a standard does that and if it
has a really low barrier of entry then
it can be successful and especially for
data formats the accessibility is very
important
because now if we remember data is the
most important asset that we generate
out of lab experimentation right it's
the results that we care about so making
them accessible that's that's also part
of the mission here alright so if there
are any questions feel free to jump in
on the conversation and and put those
into the Q&A panel and we'll take we'll
take a subset of these and then answer
them at the end of the of the session
all right we've heard about these two
families of standards that complement
each other very well let's move on to
using them to actually solve the
integration challenge in the lab of the
future and this brings all of those
things together so that I can focus on
getting the stuff done so it's about the
connectivity it's about the
sustainability of my infrastructure and
my data so let's take a look we've we've
talked earlier about how we would use a
proprietary approach to connect elements
to a balance and so on let's try to do
the same again but let's make it a bit
more complicated but this time use
standards to solve the problem much more
elegantly and in this case we'll be
using sila and animal so at the top here
I've got my lymph system and the lymph
system is supposed to interact with the
instruments in the lab because I've got
some samples set up so when I configure
my limbs what I will do is I will ask
the limbs to perform cela discovery so
discovery is a feature that's built into
serum and that means it can go around
the network and see what instruments are
there I don't have to use discovery I
can also simply configure the
instruments manually but it's a bit like
a printer driver where you plug in the
USB cable of your printer and then it
sees AHA this is the device and it
downloads the driver automatically and
and you don't have to do anything to get
it running
so it's this type of discovery where the
Lim's scans for instruments or for
sealer services that can that can do
things and then
those different services will respond so
these these respond and they say yes I'm
here I'm here
and so we hear about a balance and we
hear about a chromatography data system
they pop up and and so the Lim's
becomes aware that they exist
so the Lim's has done the discovery and
the instruments and services have
responded it now the limbs can go and
inquire about the capabilities and those
capabilities are described in features
on the Scylla side and each feature
basically defines a set of commands for
getting something done and a balance we
see that on the lower left hand side
might offer a number of Scylla features
such as device information get the
serial number the bender the model and
so on but it might also offer a weighing
feature so I can get the current weight
or I might have a way to target feature
where I say help to use a weigh in
one milligram of a substance plus minus
10% or there may be a feature to control
the door opening and closing it and for
the chromatography data system there may
be different aspects different features
that I would want so there could be
again the device information so I can
see aha I'm talking to this and this
chromatography data system in this
version I may have a sample submission
feature so that I can send samples and
create a batch or run list in that c.d.s
it's actually very interesting to
connect the CTS to our limits that way
and then on there is a batch status
feature that would allow me to control
the status of batch to see aha
which sample is already done which one
isn't so I don't have to sit around
waiting for files to appear but I can
actually get events and see in real time
aha these are the things that are going
on so the limbs is always in the picture
and it's much much more robust than the
traditional types of integration that we
used to do in past and then there may be
access to an audit trail and so on now
the Sela features describe the commands
now we also need to describe the data
that comes and documents the execution
that experiment so that's where the
animal standard brings a concept called
technique definitions and the technique
definition describes how to organize an
animal data set for a particular
measurement technique so a balance would
use the weighing technique so you would
know when was it last calibrated what
was the weight that was measured what
was the tare value was it stable and a
number of other things and also the
settings that were active on the balance
why that was the case and in the
chromatography data system there would
be different techniques that makes sense
here so animal provides ways of
describing chromatograms and spectra so
that could be the chromatography
technique a UV base technique mass spec
F ID a lot of detector techniques there
are like a dozen of them that would then
describe the data but not just the
results but potentially also the method
and the settings and so on so that again
I have reproducibility so the Lim's
looks at this right because we're still
wearing the Lim's hat so we're talking
to the balance and we're hearing how
this is what I can do and that way the
limit learns how to communicate with it
it can look at the Cielo features and
that allows the limbs to create those
commands and send them and to discover
those commands on the fly and we also
learn about the data structures which
the instrument can support and the
structures of the results so that's a
way of setting up these interfaces
without a lot of custom code and huge
projects to do the integration here you
can really discover the capability of an
instrument see what it's take a look
like and directly map that into your
workflow and that's a big benefit of
this game and from an integration
perspective that's really to me is lab
of the future so what I can do now that
I have learned from my instruments what
they can do on how to talk to them
I go to stage 5 where the limbs actually
performs the instrument control or
submit samples gets the results
and so on and we use the Cielo protocol
for the communication and we use animal
as the data transfer thing and what's
nice that once I am done with an
experiment the service can return a
complete and traceable animal data
package describing what that service did
when it was executing that command and
that gives me a complete picture and
visibility into what actually happened
so this is a way of executing these
types of interactions very very
efficiently and since nowhere in this
concept a file ever hits the disk where
it could get lost and where folder has
to be monitored I have a very high
degree of data integrity and from a
compliance perspective this is also much
preferable all right
so but now we've focused on this
communication between the limits and the
instrument obviously there's much more
because once I've done my experiments
well I now have these data packages that
describe what I did so I could do
interesting additional things on top of
that so let's look at what that could be
and here we see that the limbs or other
tools could then publish a holistic
picture of the outcome of experiments to
a global data lake where I can then go
and navigate that data mined that data
recognize trends but also archive it for
the long term and this is a very cheap
side effect that I get from setting up
my system integration that way I get
full traceability and I can repurpose
the data packages that I generate here
for many different other purposes and
this is already being done today so
we're not just talking about some future
vision or solving it but but everything
here it's actually it's actually working
and I want to show you what that what
that looks like in practice so I looked
around a little and and looked at well
what kind of measurement techniques
could we could we use as an exam and and
I found these animal measurement
techniques so this is these other
techniques that I personally know are
getting used already with animals in
production today this is the
proof of concept this is in use and I've
divided them into three categories the
first one on the left the analytical
chemistry side then in the middle more
of the biologics domain and then on the
right hand the more orthogonal
techniques that that are universally
applicable and we can see that in
analytical chemistry we have things like
HPLC GC UV vis infrared Raman mass spec
NMR and so on so the big analytical
techniques we've seen all these in the
biologic space this concept has been
applied to bio reactors micro bio
reactors plate based assays or cell
counters fire analyzers and purification
so you could you actually have people
that that that are using this to model
out an entire bio process development
pipeline and creating digital batch
records out of this and then on the
right hand side we have things like
balances pH meters imaging devices such
as microscopes or cameras by petting
liquid handling densities with density
measurements viscosity and so on so
those are those obviously fit into many
different application domains and so
what I've done is I've I've looked
around and collected a couple of data
sets convert those to animal using tools
that were available off the shelf and
then and and now we can actually look at
these so I'm using some of the tools
that we that we make in my day job in
order to to render that content on the
screen so we can actually look at that
XML content more conveniently and so now
let's look at what some of that data
looks like so here we've got an HPLC
chromatogram with a UV detector in this
case the data came from chromium and you
can see that there is that's the
chromatogram you can see the peaks are
highlighted they are annotated all of
that comes across I can switch to the
method I can switch to the sample view
I've got a bit more on
that additional contextual metadata
looks like in in some later slides and
now I can look at my chromatograms no
matter which software they came from or
which instrument they came from use the
same tool to view them to report them
and this is web-based
there are also desktop viewers available
there are there are mobile apps
available that can be used so this is
just one example and there are other
people who make them too so this is what
UV this looks like so this is a file
that originally comes from a per
container UV spectrometer and you can
see the spectrum at the top and below
not sure how big your screen is and how
well this gets across you see the
metadata in this case those were the
instrument settings broken down into
categories and that way you knew how the
spectrum was shot and then on the right
hand side you can see some additional
attributes on the sample those who are
taken from the limbs and merged into
that animal data set so that I get a
more complete data package and this can
then be stored and published and again
used outside of the instrument software
and if I have a limbs that understands
animal there are quite a few by now that
you and I can do quite interesting
things
so that's UV this this is microplate
assay and this is a data set that comes
from a token NMR and vision reader and
you can see I'm looking at that in my
web browser I have the color coding of
my of my plates so I can configure how I
want that displayed I have metadata
behind each well and I have the full
method of how the plate reader was
configured and you can even buy plate
reader software today that already makes
these animal files I think some more has
that in there scan its of there
Ramin another example Raman spectrometry
and this data comes from analyzer cue
lab and in this case I have an animal
document which contains five different
Raman spectra for our calibration scheme
to train a camel metric model so
analyzer qmix can make schema metrics
tools and here I've got all of those
spectrum in a single animal file and I
have trained my model with it and I can
now have that model executed and the
result could also go into an animal
document so this is also a very nice way
of using this technology and this is the
same software right that we used to look
at a chromatogram spectra and plate
reader data and so on so that's the
power of that's the power of the
standard where I really see as making a
big jump towards this lab of the future
idea that I get to look at the data from
all of the different experiments that I
do around my samples
and consume that on the same platform
and we happen to be doing that in the
cloud with the tools that we provide but
now you may do that on premise you may
do with that on a mobile app and
wherever you need that data that's the
promise of the lab of the future that I
have the right data and I don't have to
worry about how I got it and you know
the the environment just provides it
makes it flow in this case here we've
got a different data set which which
comes from the biologic space so this is
antibody purification done on an F PLC
and in this case it was a nectar unicorn
file from G healthcare that was
converted to animal and this is what
that looks like so I have these
thumbnails of the different detectors
that I have attached to my to my
chromatography Rick and I
see those directly and when I tap on
them with with on a touchscreen or if I
click on them with a mouse they go
fullscreen and I can actually go look at
them in more detail or overlay them or
create reports and this is again the
same tool here is an example of mass
spec data in animal and in this case the
data set comes from an Agilent mass
spectrometer and there are also
converters for for taking that data and
putting that into animal and there you
see at the top you've got your total
iron current commander ground the tick
and I've clicked on the first peak here
and I'm not sure whether that comes
across really well but you see a little
vertical marker where I clicked and then
it pulled out the spectrum underneath
and that's just in the web browser again
and now actually I've taken a different
viewer but still using the same data
format I've uploaded an NMR data file so
I can use animal also for NMR data in
this case the data comes from broken NMR
this case the topspin software was used
to create it and it was converted and so
I have my F IDs and I have my spectra in
here and this is actually an interesting
combination of multiple techniques in
the same animal document this is looking
at a cell culture where I have
bioreactor data from a satorious
bioreactor controlled by MFCs whim but I
have put that together with Infosys
analytics that I collected with roster
Dex iris which is a cell analyzer so I
got my cell counts for that and I've put
that into the same animal document so
now I can't rent these different
features of the batch inside the same
view that was really hard to do in the
past people were using complicated Excel
spreadsheets to do that and here this
can be done quite easily you can have a
single animal file for the batch you
drop in your bioreactor data during
this analytics data it snaps in on the
timeline and and you can add your
external analytics data to so if you
have let's see there's our SDS page or
western blots or so they can go into the
same animal document and you get a great
reuse of the tools and to me that is
also lab of the future so those were a
couple of examples of of the data
packages you can then actually generate
if you follow that that integration
approach and you can mix and match so
you can say oh I just want to do my
instrument control then I can use cela
for that or maybe you're not interested
in control but you only care about the
data you can use animal for that you
don't have to switch your entire lab you
can just take one instrument and play
with that a little bit and see where it
actually makes sense and it's it's it's
never a huge deal and and and huge
effort and these things are quite easy
to put together
so some key findings again and I'll
reiterate on sentence that I said
earlier that's why we care about the
results and we want to make that as
accessible as possible so that those
results can generate value and be reused
and shared with people and the lab of
the future is digital quite clearly and
it's based on openness and on
connectivity and we've seen what can be
achieved if we actually follow that that
path and the Third Point animal and Sela
we've seen that they work together very
well and they can accelerate these types
of integrations and the collaboration
between those different pieces so if you
have any questions feel free to put
those into the Q&A panel thanks so much
for your attention and for attending
this session Thank You Burke hard for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question jot down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button once there as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get it started our first
question is how can I get my instrument
data into the animal format that's an
interesting one it's a bit of a chicken
egg question because obviously we want
vendors to support this format and and
to provide that as native output from
the instrument and we are seeing a
number of instrument vendors do that psy
X for example is it's great that that
and a number of others and we're seeing
we're seeing loose companies such as
labware and and a number of eln
companies actually jump on the back
bandwagon here but if your vendor
doesn't do that then there is the there
are still third-party tools and that can
do that so so at VSN we've written a
library of about 150 of these two to get
the big things covered we obviously hope
that this will no longer be necessary in
the future that these things will come
from the vendors but if the vendor
doesn't provide them you can go to a
third party or you can even build it
yourself it's just XML and there so
there are different avenues of getting
your data into animal so Burkert what
are the vendors saying about Cielo and
animal and are they open or are they
afraid it goes into the same direction
yeah obviously there is there is this
traditional thinking where if keep my
data formats and my communication
protocols closed the customer will have
to stay with me and keep buying from me
because basically that has locked up in
that proprietary container of mine
and I think that's it that's the
thinking of the past because openness is
rewarded I buy customers so we see we
see quite a few vendors jumping on that
bandwagon because it allows them to also
generate new revenue streams right
because you because of you if you open
up and you provide tools that are open
well let's say you're you're you're
selling mass spec software suddenly your
software will be able to work with data
from a different vendor as well so your
market opens up or if you're a Lim's
companies such as labware and you are in
the business of ingesting data then
obviously reducing the number of
interfaces and that you need to support
is is a direct impact on the bottom line
so there are this so animal and Sylla
actually delivered business cases where
the people who adopt it can actually get
away cheaper than in a proprietary
setting and these are the avenues that
these communities are pursuing there are
quite a few vendors who are who are
skeptical in the beginning and some that
would probably never open up but over
the past few years the scene has changed
and people are becoming much much more
receptive so I think the time is now to
also talk to your vendor and ask about
these two in particular and I mean
because it's an L this is a there are
thousands of tools out there literally
you don't need to license anything in
particular there is no royalty so so the
the cost of entry is very low so talk to
your vendor if you if you'd like to see
this in their format our next question
what about the Internet of Things where
where do you see this lab going okay
Internet of Things is one of those
buzzwords right where we have these
connected devices and think we all have
some of them so so I think my vacuum
cleaner even has has has Wi-Fi these
days which is kind of crazy
the fact that I connect something to the
Internet doesn't mean that it's better
than before and in the lab basically
what this IOT thing means is I'm not
delivering anything that I can't do when
and when it's on-premise it's pretty
much an acronym for offering something
as a hosted service so that I have
hosted application platforms which do
have a tie-in to the instrument so I
have something that runs on premise
which I can then use and connect the
instrument to and then I have the actual
application running in the cloud and yes
strictly this is Internet of Things and
I think that's a term that's being
overused a little but maybe I should be
saying differently the lab of the future
is all about the Internet of Things
because I mean anything that has a
network port and Sina is actually being
used as a communication protocol and
I've seen a couple of prototypes where
this has been used there was a there was
also a hackathon at the pistoia Alliance
conference a couple of weeks ago where a
group actually build an IOT platform
that did web connected somehow promised
devices with some services that were on
the cloud and took the result and
presented it locally again so so
Internet of Things and lack of the
future I guess the short answer is yes
oh my god it looks like we have time for
one more question
are there any regulatory implications
when using standards regulatory
implications that obviously depends on
where you work so if you're in a
regulated environment and you fall on a
GLP or GMP you know if you're subject to
21 CFR part 11 these exact same rules
apply so there is nothing different here
and you have to have the same type of
validation that you have in a
traditional approach now some standards
are built with compliance in mind and
animal is one of them so for example
animal supports audit trails and it also
supports digital signatures so that's
kind of a sweet
because you have a you have a data
comment that's xml-based which it means
you see it's human readable but that
also means it's manipulatable but if you
put a digital signature on top of it you
can prove that the file has not been
manipulated since it was created and
that way the instrument can actually
sign for the content it created and in a
number of jurisdictions that digital
signature mechanism that animal uses is
actually equal as a handwritten
signature and that gives you a very nice
way of achieving compliance by
demonstrating your chain of custody of
the data and and building a nice data
integrity star I would like to once
again thank Burkhart for hism for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab birds for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2018
you will receive an email from labyrinth
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye